hello everyone I'm Hajime and thank you
for coming to my talk I'll be speaking
about media mix modeling so let's get
started
this is an agenda for my talk
first I will explain the background and
concept of mmm
and then I will cover data preparation
modeling and demo with lightweight mmm
and insights and actions at the end of
the talk I will offer some practical
recommendations
for the sake of time please save your
questions until the end
one quick note if you if you are
interested in learning more about this
slide demo code reference for this talk
please go to Pi data Global schedule
page and click my talk I listed some
links
so just a quick introduction
are Pi data Global there are so many
famous speakers but I think most of you
don't know me so let me introduce myself
very quickly to explain my motivation
behind this talk today
I have close to five years of experience
in data science data analytics of
marketing retail e-commerce area
after I graduated from Kyoto University
with the Masters in computer science I
worked as a data analyst at Brockton
Gumball Japan
Proctor gamble is well known for its
organized marketing strategy and
currently I am responsible for the
e-commerce business of a Japanese
clothing brand looking to expand into
the U.S market
also I manage and optimize the
performance of advertisements at my
current company
I believe advertising and marketing is
an intriguing topic for pilot audience
because every company spends money on
advertisement
so today I want to talk about media mix
modeling
so from my from this presentation My
Hope Is that you will gain a basic
understanding of my key Concepts on
approaches of media mix modeling
also I hope this talk motivates you to
try modeling in your environment
first
I'd like to talk about what media mix
modeling is
what comes to your mind when you hear
the word advertisement
let give let me give you some examples
TV commercials are a common approach
social media as like when you check your
friend's post or videos on social media
platforms you probably see many ads also
if you Google something you usually can
see some ads at the top of the result
also us on buses airports trains or
taxis on buildings think Times Square
known as oh out of home advertising are
fairly common
media optimization has been a challenge
for a long time
some of you might be familiar with the
marketing pioneer
John Wanamaker
he supposedly said
half the money I spend on Advertising is
wasted
the trouble is I don't know which half
a statistical approach for solving this
question is called media mix modeling or
marketing model marketing mix modeling
it is generally referred to as mmm for
short
the purpose of mmm is to understand how
much each marketing media contributes to
sales
and how much money should be spent on
each
for many decades companies with huge
advertising budget in the beverage
consumers old and faster industry
has been have been working on improving
mmm
also other tech companies such as Google
and meta have been focusing on mmm
actively these days
you might wonder why it is so difficult
to measure our life or why not just
check all the way on the report issued
by each media
these are very good questions but the
reality is a little more little more
complicated
the first reason is that the end user
has multiple media touch points and the
media channel interfere in influences
are intertwining
secondly tracking accuracy is not always
correct
offline media channel influence is hard
to track
for example print media such as
newspapers or magazines we can't track
how many people actually see the ads in
that form of media
what is worse
even in the digital world privacy
regulations such as gdpl and Apple's
idfa deprecation have been impacting
tracking accuracy
thirdly randomized experiments known as
a lift test are impractical
the gold standard for answering a
cause-up question is to perform a
randomized experiment by randomly
splitting a population into a test group
and a control group where the test group
has no advertisements
however
This is Not Practical because companies
prefer not to risk restrict ad
for a long time as this could lead to
Lost opportunities
this slides shows the definition and the
purpose of mmm
mmm are statistical models which help in
quantifying the impact of several
marketing inputs on self
roughly if eating there are three goals
the first goal is to understand and
measure return on investment Roi for
example the model will tell you your Roi
on TV last year
the second objective is simulation
for example with this
you will be able to find out what your
sales would be like if more or less
money you are spent on TV the following
year
the third one is optimizing Media budget
this step will help you to optimize
budget allocation which will contribute
to maximizing cells
this shows the entire mmm steps
the first step is data preparation
the next step is modeling and then
insights and actions
in this talk
I will go over each step in detail
next adjective cover data preparation
thank you so this is a quick preview of
the input data for the mmm model
we use time series data and we don't use
any privacy related data
as you can see we have a weak
cells media spending and other data
columns
let me deep dive into what kind of data
is needed
the first part is the most important
metric which is the kpi of your business
and this will be a dependent variable
if you are a retailer or a manufacturer
sales is a common choice
however if you are a mobile app company
the number of apps installed will be the
kpi
next
explanatory variables uh potential
factors that impact sales
media data is mandatory because we want
to optimize these allocations
and non-media marketing data such as
price promotion price and price
distribution affects sales
external factors such as seasonality
holiday weather
or macroeconomy
data are also important to increase the
model accuracy
in this side I'm going to talk about the
data granularity required for mmm
there are three things that I want to
cover
in terms of time mmms often require two
to three years of the weekly level data
however if you don't have that much data
daily data is also accept acceptable but
in that case you will need to be more
careful in reviewing the iCloud years
the next is business granularity
the common approach is to correct brand
or business unit level data for example
Procter Gamble has Pantene head and
shoulders and Herbal Essence in the
haircut category
and each brand team has a different
cells marketing and media strategy
make sure to determine the data
granularity based on the product line
organization and decision making process
when looking at media spending data a
common granularity is the media channel
level such as TV print oh and digital
but it depends on how much you are
spending on each media
for example if you spend a lot of
digital us
it is better to break down the digital
channel into more specific groups such
as Google search as Google display us
YouTubers Facebook ads and Etc because
Google search ads and YouTubers have
different funnels and roles
next I'll explain the modeling
first let's start by considering simple
moving
linear regression on observational data
is a common method that has
traditionally been used
here cells is the objective variable and
media spending factors and control
factors are explanatory variables
these coefficients mean the impact on
cells
so better m is the coefficient of the
media variables and better C is the
coefficient of the control variable such
as seasonality or price change
the most significant advantage of this
method is that everyone can run it very
quickly because even Excel has a
regression progression function also
it's easy for everyone including
non-tech Executives to understand the
results intuitively
however this method is not grounded in
key marketing principles that are widely
accepted by the marketing industry
these are there are two add principles
to consider saturation and ad stock
let's first take a look at saturation
the effectiveness of one media Channel's
advertisements the case
as the expenditure increases
let me say that in a different way
the more money you spend on one media
channel advertisement
the less effective it is
and this is a saturation this is also
called The Shape effect
the second principle is a carry over
effect
the advertising effect on cells May lag
behind the initial exposure and extend
several weeks because consumers
generally remember us for an extended
period of time
but they sometimes delay action
there are several reasons why
consumers don't purchase the items
immediately if they already have home
stock
or if they plan to purchase expensive
items such as a PC furniture or TV
they may take several days to several
weeks to consider purchasing the icons
these examples are what cause the
carryover effect
researchers at Google proposed a method
that reflects these two features in
2017.
I'll elaborate a bit more in the next
slide
the first technique is heal function
this function will transform media
spending to curvature function
there are two parameters here SM is a
part shape parameter which is also
referred to as slope
and km is the half saturation point
as image on the right size this function
can represent various shapes of the
saturation curve by changing these
parameters
the second technique is the other
stockhold function which is useful for
representing the carryover effect
the cumulative media effect is a
weighted average of media spending in
the current week and the previous L
minus one week
here L is the maximum duration of the
carryover effect
and we can use different
functional forms for weight function WM
a commonly used function is geometric
Decay which is the block curve in the
chart
also if the radical kernel basis
function is used for the weight function
the other stock function will be like
the lead curve in the graph
this curve may work better if the
product or media has a larger due to the
derived consumer response I mentioned
about
so let's return to the basic formula
here
this is the final model that reflects
the carryover effect and this and other
saturation
the basic approach is the same as the
simple model I shared earlier
cells can be decomposed into Baseline
cells media factors control factors and
white noise and in this formula
coefficients better
represents the impact of each step each
practice
the target variable is sales per time
period
the change here is to apply two
transformation functions to the time
series of the media spending
saturation and other sub function
control factors are the other factors
that could influence cells and the Epson
in this case is the white noise
so
I will go over the demo
here let me introduce two great overseas
library that will help you to try mmm
the first one is lightweight mmm
developed by
uh mainly by Google developers and the
second one is Robin developed by meta
engineers
both libraries reflect other stock and
saturation functions the biggest
difference is the lightweight mmm you is
a big python-based Library while Robin
is a an all-based rivalry
lightweight mmm uses non-pyro when Jacks
for probabilistic part programming which
makes the modeling process much faster
on top of the standard approach
lightweight mmm offers a hierarchical
approach if you have state level or
Regional level data this geo-based
hierarchical approach can build more
accurate results
while Robin makes use of metals AI
Library System
never grad is used for hyper parameter
optimization and profit is adopted for
100 time series data
I am shame the that most of today's
audience prefer python so I'll do a
quick demo with lightweight mmm
so before doing the demo let me just
show you the flowchart of lightweight mm
one
preparing the data and two training the
model
diagnose the model get an optimized
budget recommendation and saving load
module
so
let's do
so I'm going to use Google Cloud to show
you the demo
just as a reminder if you want to
download My Demo code please go to my
pilot Global schedule page and click my
talk
and my code is based on the sample
script that is available on lightweight
mmm repository on GitHub
first let's install the lightweight mmm
Library using Pap command
it should take about one to two minutes
if you get the error restart runtime
you need to click the restart runtime
button
also
let's import some libraries such as juxt
numpyro and necessary modules from the
app lightweight mmm
next let's prepare the data
the official sample script uses a
simulated dead set that is generally by
the libraries function to create tummy
data however
I'm going to use really more realistic
data
in this session
I found a good data set on a GitHub
repository
mmm stand
I'm not sure whether this data set it is
real dummy or simulated data but for me
it looks more realistic than any other
data I found on the internet
let's take a quick look at it
this data contains four years of records
of data at the weekly level
for Simplicity
I use seven media channels for media
spending data and holiday and seasonal
information for control variables
next
I'm going to pre-process the data
we split the data set into train and
test
I'm leaving 24 only the last 24 weeks
for testing in this case
also this Library provides a custom
scaling function for pre-processing in
this demo we divide the media spending
data extra features data and the target
data by their mean to ensure that the
result has a mean of one
this allows the model to be agnostic to
the scale of the inputs
the next is training
we can choose an understocked function
for the modeling from three options
here are the stroke add stock and
carryover
it is generally recommended to compare
all three approaches and use the
approach that works the best
and then execute the modeling using the
fit function
training tags about 20 minutes
depending on your environment
once training is finished you can check
the summary of your Trace
the important Point here is to check
whether our heart values or or
parameters are less than 1.1
this is a checkpoint when you when you
run Basel modeling
also we can visualize the posterior
distributions of the media effect
and this is optional but you can
visualize the prior and posterior
distributions for every model parameter
at once
now let's do a fitting check
your model speed to the training data
can also be checked by using plot model
feed function
r squared and map mean absolute positive
elements are shown in the chart
in this example r squared is 0.9 and
mape is 23 percent
for our next step I'll do a fitting
check using the test date set
generally speaking R square is
considered good if it is more than 0.8
also for map the goal is for it to be 20
or below
and this is the visualization of the
prediction result
R square here is 0.62 and map is 23
percent
earnesty the Earl square and map
variance here are not ideal however
I do not have any additional data and
I'm not even sure whether this data set
is real or a dummy that said I'm still
going to be using this data set and
modeling to show you the insights
I'll be going over how to improve the
model in more details later in this talk
now I'm going to go back to the slide to
explain the outcome and insights
we can quickly visualize the estimated
media and Baseline contribution over
time by using this function
this graph shows that about 70 percent
of cells are Baseline cells which is
represented by the Blue Area the other
colors shows media contribution to the
remaining cells
this graph shows the estimated Loi of
each media channel
each bar represents how efficient the
ROI of the media is in this case TV and
online display data display media are
more efficient than other media
looking at the result overall this
company's marketing activities work
quite well
with this command
we can visualize the optimized Media
budget allocation
the graph showed the previous budget
allocation and optimized budget
allocation
in this case Direct Mail
and radio should be reduced and other
media should be increased
summary
so is mmm practical I think so if you
don't want a maker were alive today I
would advise him
follow the following you should try mmm
however a tailor-made model is needed
for better insights and actions because
there is no one-size-fits-all model as
every business is in a different
situation
then how do we improve model accuracy
for better insights and actions
first of all better data is important
you need to choose the control variables
carefully that affect yourself based on
your business
Google researchers into identify that
search volume for Relevant queries can
be used in mmm to control the impact of
paid research as appropriated
you if you spend a lot on a specific
media channel it is better to break down
the media channel into more specific
groups
the next next recommendation is to
improve the modeling
of course hyper parameter tuning is
important
in addition to the trying the geo-level
hierarchical approach is a good way to
get a better accuracy
the further recommendation is to work
with your marketing team and do actual
experiments known as a lift test as
previously mentioned it is unrealistic
to do randomized experiments in all
media however experimentation at key
points is useful to get the ground truth
to improve the model
meta recently released the glift which
is an OSS solution that can be useful
for geo-based experimentation
so this is a quick sum this is a summary
of my talk so I explained about the mmm
and I explained the concept of
saturation and artistic function if you
are familiar with python lightweight mmm
is a
good first step
so
this is the reference of the talk
and thank you for your time if you have
any questions or comments please feel
free to contact me
so thank you very much
oh and definitely thank you we have a
couple of seconds where
uh still waiting on the next speaker to
show up I've got oh there she is but
still uh wonderful Taco Jimmy thank you
so much one of the most detailed and
application oriented Triple M talks I've
listened to
and uh summon Mark Warren asked have you
tried Robin
Robin
uh yes I tried Robin and Robin ha is
released two to three years ago so it
offers a lot of
uh options and in terms of algorithm
lobbying is a little bit different from
uh lightweight MMA but maybe you have
time I think a lot both Robin and
lightweight mmm uh good Library so maybe
you have time
trying both Solutions might be good